[Music]
in the fatal foreplay news submitted by
taste the rainbow
a woman admitted to stabbing her husband
to death with a 14-inch dagger during
foreplay oh [ __ ] this crazy
where did she stab him in the heart
I know what the [ __ ] I don't know about
that it's a it's an excuse I wouldn't
put money on that blood play is the most
dangerous form uh yes I am yeah yes I'm
play that's a term people like to in
like like vampire and stuff man yeah
okay so this woman she's from West
Virginia and she stabbed her husband
with the 14-inch dagger decorative
dagger oh that's not even so it's not
even sharp
what is that letter opener yeah what is
it that creative me I can't tell you I
just that's how they I think it's not
meant for actually used all right I was
like no blade stole yeah that's my doll
what's probably like the blade is dull
but there could be a point yeah looking
like a letter opener yep
like I said also be squiggly just like
but that's so [ __ ] specific like
she's like maybe the blade there's only
like how that is a they would have said
letter letter opener good point
no I don't know for some reason I
pictured these guys like they're into
some sort of like fantasy stuff and like
they have like midwifing yeah like a
LARPing kind of yeah picture like the
dagger to have like a it's like a
dragon's mouth and then like a blade is
coming out of it and yeah I was I was
picture he's dressed in a Starfleet
costume and she's got a Klingon bat'leth
and then she's just opening up letters
yeah so she has now pleaded guilty to
having [ __ ] kinky ass sex
that's right so she pleaded guilty to
the charge of voluntary manslaughter
over the death of her husband back in
November 2017 whoops in their home so
she was sentenced to 15 years in prison
Oh B 15:01 v Quinto pre-read she
probably pled guilty to get a lesser
sentence it's probably a guilty
conscience they're saying is killing my
husband in women jail like a pretty sick
thing you probably get a couple of
high-fives for that I feel like it
depends like if they're like oh [ __ ]
with you like a bag dude you know like
now we were [ __ ] they're like yeah
that's then don't feel sorry for you
yeah yeah so she understand this quote
my husband and I like to fight and have
sex and then make up if that's if that's
the right way to say that he was a crime
that I'm guilty he wasn't supposed to
get hurt but it did happen
we need more details ya know about that
okay so listen she ended up she changed
her her story many times oh so she
killed um yeah she's really kinky kinky
[ __ ] she's like [ __ ] I can't reveal this
about myself
what did she stab his ass like a million
times yeah she's like oh he really liked
it she's trying to honor his like life
now she doesn't want to like bring shame
to you that's what she changed the story
so many times she murdered him yeah so
in one story she said that he had
slipped in water and fell on a
screwdriver because it actually he got
stabbed in the neck
Oh penetrated his heart oh okay that is
not an accident bro that so she tried to
claim that gravity he fell backwards it
felt perfectly honest she watches too
many cartoons because she fall backwards
she tried with the banana peel at first
yeah I'm gonna work good chance though
state water and then the other story
this is when Steve is correct and hurt
this one story she said that he had
backed into a letter opener
I'll be damned another over you got
hanging off the wall well vindicated in
a horizontal position like someone just
decorative dagger oh it was meant to
stick out the wall thank you
so what this guy opens the door and he
sees a bunch of knives laid out all over
the ground and [ __ ] and on the walls - I
know normal for him I could see though
in a world if they really were into some
super duper freaky kinky a [ __ ] and she
was embarrassed to admit it she was just
like uh-uh he backed into the wall and
there was a letter over instead of just
being like we like to cut each other
right yeah
gnarly but hey how many times was he
stabbed
there's the from what I understand one
time the heart to the heart oh that's
crazy so they are saying that the police
are saying that she did have a history
of domestic violence
oh one really she tried to use a car to
run over her husband Oh Oh God
she bent on to kill this money she only
get 15 years for killing her husband
because you pleaded guilty there's so
much evidence against her she's madly in
love she's probably trying to drown her
husband in the bathtub before what if
that is still foreplay for him though
rotting in the bath like pretending like
it being choked yeah you think a victim
I'm like no don't run me over don't do
all this girl [ __ ] he's like right
rock-hard raunchy people are [ __ ] this
is like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] pretend to
be a homeless man up and pushing the
shopping cart just run me over and then
when she hits him with the car he
yeah he hits the car and he does one of
those cartoon dog shake like I get
electrocuted in the car he gets 40 uh
have you seen those like Russian scam
ones where like the car pulls up and in
they go oh we're at McDonald's when they
slip on my guys or something and then
they're like oh casinos in Vegas like
yeah like oh Jesus
that probably happens when we think yeah
damn sorry for those guys initially she
was charged with murder but then like
they had set up the whole jury and
everything and then she ended up being
like uh uh guilty it's the lesser lesser
charge she's just working this system
right now yeah so they're saying that
the that alcohol was probably a factor
in the death no she's [ __ ] cuckoo
yeah it's just crazy and then the
defense attorney said quote as strangest
as this is they watched these kung fu
movies and it led to what I would tell a
jury foreplay which was both of them
getting pretty violent with each other
while playing with weapons oh yeah what
happened to her I don't know anyone that
got horny from watching kung fu movies
what's his vigil bike so this is Jenna
got a look at the eyebrows also he's
just crazy it's look at the eyebrows
Jennifer oh it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah soup sprays I like just picturing
her watching kung fu movies and like a
kid like kicking around in the living
room yeah and this is Thomas or was
savage tip here's the thing what kind of
dumbass jury doesn't see that she tried
to run over her husband already change a
story changes his story three times and
is like it shouldn't mean it well she's
guilty no they didn't even there wasn't
even a jury always the judge won it was
just that she took a plea deal you
didn't even go to that trash trick to
please well there's an option where it's
like you don't do the jury but it's just
the judge decides I don't know it's
called no lawyer I know you're saying I
you communicated would be successful
okay
the judge
you should be a lawyer you know
everything if you were for the internet
what people think
oh no internet you know every don't
listen an EMI of my opinions or my
decision making is for folks get off the
show immediately because all we do is
talk about [ __ ] we absolutely no hard
evidence domestic violence happens from
women - that's the moral Vasanti you
know what I heard we learned
statistically in domestic violence
situations females actually hit more
than guys do but we go like this yeah I
mean there's no damage right yeah so
like the damage is on the hearts yeah
but there's like the guys can't hit them
back so they feel like they can yeah
there's less there's less I guess volume
from from guys doing it because they
know that if they do there's more damage
earlier today we saw at Disneyland brawl
that's right he [ __ ] them up he [ __ ]
up some win we're talking about macro
statistics not anecdotal but yeah not
drawing people it does anyway yeah the
ladies did get up though these guys I
swear to God they would only hit the
women they were fighting each other it
was like the two guys and the woman here
yelling he's crazy
anyway back to this whole previous
sexual foreplay that she's trying to say
do you guys ever get crazy violent crazy
no violence
you think it'd be turned on by that kind
of stuff yeah you would yeah but not to
that extreme if I slapped you around
yeah I've asked you to slap me like I
can do it I can slap you in the face
yeah sure now you [ __ ] [ __ ] do it
I [ __ ] cause I'm scared cuz like he
doesn't know how to do it just yet cuz
he'll go like no that's ex slappy yeah I
don't understand you're like pain and
door friends are like diminished when
you're aroused so like you can withstand
more pain when you're around like you
don't follow through it sure if she
wants to like fight oh yeah that's the
hard part because I know what
look I know what fighting feels like
using I wipe the seat up and I know what
[ __ ] feels like but I'm scared
I will hospitalized her yeah me too I'm
[ __ ] scared [ __ ] under control and
that's got a normal you shouldn't just
like let loose like a wild has made a
combined that's the part like tonight
I'll call my school psych hold you like
[ __ ] you and then have my hammer your
neck and then oh geez like Jews like I
want a fight [ __ ] and Bart dragon kicks
your oh that's not it you should start
small with like a little bit of like a
whip or something but you know like a
flogger a flogger you don't need a lot
I'm here what yeah go get a proper intro
man but it longer doesn't require
strength by flogger I don't know what is
that called that's just like a whip the
weather whip that's what we have no
questions so I just kind of like yeah it
should be like this should be like whoa
kind of hurts well yeah right now but if
you work hard
it wouldn't hurt yeah yeah oh we're
gonna experiment I don't know about that
I don't know if guys experience the same
cuz if if all the Bloods rushing to that
one area and then I get smacked in the
face the Bloods gonna rush it I don't
want to smack him in the face I want him
to smack me oh I see yeah yeah I want to
I want to get to grade it a little bit I
get it is that hold I'm pain is pleasure
thing I've heard a lot from women not
that much from guys mm-hmm dude if you
guys know you guys are a slap of girls
around or like putting on the ass yeah I
thought the ass yeah and then I cried no
yes she whipped
he's loved her yeah is that the Bellagio
it was was that after you guys on your
Vegas trip no a long time I never forgot
that picture that fountain [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
you